[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 2 c'est une
édition un peu particulière puisque nous
sommes au salon international de
l'agriculture à paris un événement qui
attire plus de six cent mille visiteurs
ils viennent découvrir les animaux de la
ferme les agriculteurs et les
producteurs et les yvelinois sont encore
au rendez vous cette année
[Musique]
dans un instant nous irons rencontrer
paul in vino pour lefebvre
vice-présidente en charge de la ruralité
au conseil départemental des yvelines
mais pour l'instant nous sommes sur le
stand de deux producteurs de biscuits
yvelinois les deux gourmands ils
fabriquent par exemple ces biscuits au
chocolat c'est pain d'épicés ou encore
du miel des produits vendus à la fois en
supermarché mais aussi à la ferme
découverte de cette filière avec nicolas
kérino vite c'est patrick jacques de
dixmude du biscuit et du miel made in
yvelines dans un rayon de supermarché ou
la rencontre de la grande distribution
et du local avec un équilibre gagnant
gagnant a trouvé entre la direction du
magasin et le producteur c'est lui qui
est venu me voir alors à près de face au
vent nous ont fait des recherches
on va visiter un peu les artisans du
coin là c'est lui qui est de nous voir
avec ces biscuits qu'on a goûté qu'on a
adoré
le but c'est de bâtir internet ensemble
donc on réfléchit le juge de paix ses
clients toujours donc le bon prix c'est
le prix que le client est prêt à payer
pour une qualité une production locale
dont les secrets sont gardés dans cette
ferme à crêpière par les deux gourmands
biscuits miel et pain d'épicés ont
d'abord vendu dans cette boutique
les relations avec la grande
distribution se sont-elles construite
dans un second temps je pense que pour
travailler avec l'essentiel on travaille
il fallait être prêt c'est-à-dire être
capable de répondre à une demande un peu
plus importante maintenant faut quand
même savoir que la grande distribution
peut travailler en direct avec des
petits producteurs comme nous ce qui
rend finalement la chose
plus facile installé depuis cinq ans
guillaume caffin et louis bataille ont
commencé leur activité avec la
fabrication de biscuits à partir de
matières premières locales valeurs
essentielles des deux gourmands
le point de départ c'est vraiment la
région ces terroirs et de d'apporter un
peu plus ce qu'il manque dans
l'agroalimentaire selon nos deux de
transparence de proximité et devrait
elle la fabrication du miel est né de la
rencontre entre les deux entrepreneurs
et l'apiculteur antoine édoin il y a
trois ans ils sont aujourd'hui associé
le miel récolté au printemps et en été
il est ensuite travaillé lors de l'hiver
ici on a la garantie de proposer au
consommateur amiel qui est uniquement
retravailler à froid et qui donc va
garder une entièreté de ses propriétés
telles que celles que vous avez dans les
ruches j'ai eu cette volonté de me
rapprocher du consommateur de pouvoir
expliquer comme je le fais aujourd'hui
bah la particularité de mes produits ma
façon de travailler le fait qu'on puisse
produire des produits de qualité en ile
de france aux portes de paris on peut
avoir des des miels brut qui sont
véritablement le symbole de nos terroirs
du gastines et de fleurs ou de forêts
différents types de produits qui rendent
mielleuse la boutique des deux gourmands
avec 43 % de surfaces agricoles et plus
de 1000 exploitations les yvelines se
classe deuxième territoire agricole
d'île de france et pour parler de ce
secteur d'activité je suis avec pauline
dino pour le faire ou sur le stand
yvelines hauts-de-seine bonsoir ça
alors vous êtes vice présidente en
charge de la ruralité au conseil
départemental des yvelines
pourquoi avez vous décidé de faire un
instant de commun avec le département
des hauts-de-seine alors d'abord parce
qu'on est engagé dans un projet de
fusion de nos deux départements avec une
mutualisation d'un certain nombre de
services
d'où ce stand commun ensuite parce qu'il
ya une complémentarité entre nos deux
territoires
nous on est un territoire vous l'avez
rappelé essentiellement rural eu son
plus urbain
en gros pour caricaturer un peu on est
les producteurs et les consommateurs on
a bien sûr des consommateurs dans les
yvelines
mais un potentiel notamment sur le sujet
de la restauration scolaire et le
collège est une compétence
départementale qui est qui est important
et qui permettrait de valoriser nos
productions locales
alors pour revenir justement la
production locale la production
yvelinoise je le rappelle les chiffres
43 % de surfaces agricoles plus de 1000
exploitations
qu'est ce qui constitue cette dynamique
par rapport à l'agriculture yvelinoise
c'est une agriculture alors on est un
département essentiellement grandes
cultures
et on a une agriculture très innovante
qui se réinvente qui réinvente ses
modèles on a le secteur agricole et est
en grande difficulté je pense que ça a
été pas mal rappelé cette semaine
notamment à l'occasion de ce salon de
l'agriculture
et on a des agriculteurs qui
diversifient qui essaye de se rapprocher
du consommateur et de faire perdurer
leur exploitation ce qui est absolument
essentiel parce que quand une fermez pas
reprises on se retrouve avec une friche
est une friche c'est un paysage qui
change c'est un paysage qui peut être
limité et urbanisé du coup voilà il faut
pas oublier ce qu'on doit à nos
agriculteurs et à leur activité qui est
une activité économique avant tout qui
façonnent nos paysages et l'enjeu des
agriculteurs
et du coût du travail qu'on mène avec
eux c'est de maintenir ces exploitations
qu'elle soit viable à qu'elles soient
transmissibles et qu'elle permet de
faire vivre nos paysages et de générer
une activité économique est essentielle
pour nos territoires et comment le
département participe à cette dynamique
nous avons des dispositifs pour aider
les agriculteurs
on a des dispositifs de soutien à leurs
investissements pour notamment sur des
projets de diversification par exemple
un plan des deux
qu'on a mis en place au moment des
épisodes de gel très important en
15 ou 2016 9016 et puis la sécheresse
ah oui c'était en 2016 mais c'était pas
sur la même période de culture
la sécheresse avec plus touché la grande
culture donc on a ces dispositifs de
soutien en cas de
d'incidents climatiques vous allez
justement renouvelé
une enveloppe peut-être voter une
nouvelle enveloppe par rapport aux
dernières intempéries on sait que le
territoire notamment le nord du
territoire des yvelines a été touchée
est ce que vous envisagez une enveloppe
alors pour l'instant je n'ai pas de
retour chiffres et je sais pas quel est
l'impact a été assez tôt dans la saison
par rapport
à la fois dernière sauf erreur de ma
part mais en tout cas il ya une volonté
du département de pérenniser et surtout
de prévoir un dispositif qu'on puise
qu'on soit pas obligé de remettre en
place dans l'urgence à chaque fois et
qu'on ait quelque chose de pérenne
pour soutenir les agriculteurs alors
qu'on débloque si calamité îliens et
puis s'il n'y a pas tant mieux et et
tout va bien
dans le meilleur des mondes mais voilà
il ya cette volonté là évidemment
pauline vidéo cours lefebvre merci et
nous poursuivons ce set 8 dossiers au
salon international de l'agriculture
avec d'autres acteurs yvelinois
[Musique]
nous sommes avec les mérinos de la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet les
150 femelles et un mâle permettre à des
chercheurs de travailler sur cette
espèce historique de moutons mais la
bergerie nationale c'est aussi de
l'élevage de vaches laitières seul est
certifiée biologique permet de produire
de la mozzarella un reportage d'aurélie
ronces et de patrick jacques de dixmude
à dakar après l'appel à -1
depuis un peu plus d'un an sarah lacombe
a produit des burrata au sens de
l'atelier de transformation de lait bio
de la bergerie nationale
originaire de la région des pouilles en
italie ce fromage onctueux effet à
partir de mozzarella d'une grosse partie
de ce travail qui se fait à la main
notamment l'effilochage de la mozzarella
et après on s'aide avec la façonneuse
pour pour sortir non aux feuilles et en
fait on pèse tout ça quatre personnes
travaillent ici en bas saison comme
c'est le cas actuellement
l'atelier accueille également un autre
partenaire la ferme de sigy qui
transforme une partie du lait en yaourt
des produits bio évidemment puisque le
précieux nectar blanc a été certifié
biologique en mai 2016
une consécration pour la bergerie
nationale et sa soixantaine de vaches
laitières
nous fournissons le lait
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée c'est à
peu près mille litres de lait produits
chaque jour qui sont transformés sur
place
le lait entre les tables et l'atelier de
transformation ne parcourt que 300 m
environ
un circuit court qui permet à la ferme
de sigy de produire davantage de yaourt
bio pour la société autant tas de sarah
la combat il n'y a que des avantages à
être ici on est un circuit fermé
donc quelque part le lait qui est
produit n'est produit que pour nous et
pour la ferme de sigy donc il y à aussi
vraiment un
une attention de la part des éleveurs
vis-à-vis des des qualités que le lait
elle doit avoir conquis soit convenable
pour nous français c'est exceptionnel
depuis plus de 20 ans la bergerie
nationale travaillent sur le thème de
l'agroécologie cet atelier de
transformation de lait bio était donc la
suite logique et aujourd'hui grâce à ces
à ce partenariat nous savons que nos
produits sont commercialisés
essentiellement en ile de france
donc nous produisons bien et nous
commercialisons bien et locales des
burrata extra frêche qui se retrouve
notamment à la carte de restaurant et
palaces parisiens un fromage à déguster
plus particulièrement au printemps car
c'est à cette période qu'elle serait la
plus savoureuse
la grille 4.0 quand l'agriculture
rencontre le numérique différentes
technologies utilisées par les
agriculteurs dans le cadre de leurs
activités
c'est le cap d'amaury babeau responsable
de la ferme de la brosse dans le sud i
mean un document signé michael et demi
d'euros et quentin le frère
on est parti c'est devenu un outil de
son quotidien depuis trois ans plusieurs
fois par semaine a mûri babeau jeunes
agriculteurs de 27 ans sort son drôle
pour contrôler les 160 hectares
d'exploitation de la ferme de la brosse
sans se déplacer sur le téléphone j'ai
la joie la caméra du drone est en fait
après j'ai un joystick pour montées
descentes et accélérer freiner puis
après j'ai un bouton pour prendre des
photos un bouton pour prendre des vidéos
en exploitation les champs en parallèle
de son drone personnel à bord y fait
également appel à une société extérieure
qu'il rémunère 10 euros de l'hectare
pour étudier du ciel ces parcelles via
des drôles professionnels et de l'est
thermiques sont ensuite envoyées à
l'exploitant plus et rouge - il ya deux
feuilles et moyens de culture et plus et
vert foncé plus il ya de feuilles et
plus de culture donc ça veut dire que là
où il ya plus de feuilles plus de
culture on apportera moins d'engrais que
là où il y en a moins autre
investissement consenti par cet
agriculteur en 2012
un gps est 12000 euros pour ce prix les
radars sont précis entre 2 et 10 cm sur
les modèles l'antenne c'est elle qui est
directement liée au satellite qui permet
de savoir on est dans le champ et puis
après à l'intérieur on a un écran qui
permet de visualiser ce que volonté
objectif répartir de façon homogène
l'engrais sur les parcelles ce système
lui permet de gagner près d'une heure et
demie sur une journée
on pas jamais deux fois au même endroit
et au moins comme ça la pénibilité en
est moins fatigué à suivre le traceur
toute la journée
on est plus concentré sur la machine et
à régler l'outil
arrières un gain de temps et un confort
de travail surtout aussi aujourd'hui cet
agriculteur 2.0 veut continuer à
investir dans de nouvelles technologies
et prévoit l'achat dans les deux ans
d'une machine pour désherber qui
fonctionnerait avec des caméras
autoguidés coût total de l'opération
vaut mille euros c'est la fin de ce sept
huit dossiers au salon de l'agriculture
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet ou sur l'application
mobile tv 78 on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour l'ouverture d'un nouveau
dossier
[Musique]